[Music]
i don't know what i'm doing wrong
i've lost my influence maybe it's time i
retired the coat
you still have it some kids with a deer
rifle put two holes in the sleigh
wanting me
all i have is a loathing for a world
that's forgotten
the united states military would like to
procure your services this is one time
deal gentlemen
how are you mike nicole and the kids are
well i hope
where are you
[Music]
what's the job i'd like you to kill
santa claus
i'm looking for the fat man you can't be
serious
this is what people actually think of me
christmas is a farce i am a joke what's
the purpose of your visit
hunting i'm gonna kill some things there
is a
rising number of our youth making poor
decisions
what the big man's head severed heads
rot they mold they don't want his beard
i'm not shaving off a dead man's beard
your workers sure have healthy appetites
that's why elves live much longer than
humans
and chris he does the same
no it's a giving that keeps him young
[Music]
you think you're the first
i think i got this job because i'm fat
and jolly
[Music]
the fat man's got his eye on you kids
clean off
[Music]
you